[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de
l'intelligence des territoires parler
d'intelligence des territoires peut
faire l'effet d'un oxymore car cela
consiste à allier ce qui relève de
l'esprit dont l'humain et le porteur
privilégié et le territoire qui
constitue notre environnement naturel
avec sa biodiversité
ses paysages et l'air qu'on y respire la
contradiction n'est qu'apparente parce
qu'il revient à l'espèce humaine
d'aménager les territoires qui constitue
notre monde social économique culturel
écologique politique même avec les
mobilités qui vont avec depuis que la
transition énergétique va de pair avec
une transition numérique en train de
chambouler nos modes de vie nos facteurs
de production nos modes de transport le
travail et la consommation nous allons
aborder successivement la place des
territoires sur l'échiquier national
du point de vue économique
du point de vue social du point de vu de
la configuration spatiale également des
échanges commerciaux
que signifie habiter le territoire que
signifie si éduquer s'y faire soigner
travailler lieu de toutes sortes
d'activités les territoires dispose
également de ressources pas seuls pleut
mans alimentaire mais également
énergétique hydrique est également cette
conquête économique dont on parle tant
et qui passe par la réindustrialisation
du pays enfin les territoires sont
désormais connectés
connectés signifie donc le avec un
numérique qui nous rend les territoires
intelligent et dont nous allons parler
avec mes invités alors je vous présente
mes invités françois rebsamen vous êtes
maire de dijon et président de dijon
métropole hélène peskine vous êtes
architecte urbaniste
secrétaire permanente du puca patrice
vergriete vous êtes
maire de dunkerque et président de la
communauté urbaine jean hervé lorenzi
aux est fondateur du cercle des
économistes et président des rencontres
d'aix-en-provence
[Musique]
dans le mille feuille territorial
d'aujourd'hui tout se mêle et tout
s'emmêle
décentralisation incomplète territoire
d'abandon compétences disputé
concurrence entre localités et
mondialisation faut-il prévoir une
espèce de planification territoriale en
matière d'aménagement des territoires et
qui serait en connexion avec la
planification écologique
hélène pasquet
alors je me méfie un peu de ce terme de
planification à l'échelle nationale qui
a une histoire en france longue
notamment après la seconde guerre
mondiale qui était une histoire très
descendante et donc avec l'idée qu'on
pouvait depuis paris finalement définir
quel serait l'avenir du territoire
national à travers un certain nombre
d'orientations
sur des zones géographique déterminée
avec des des filières économiques
préfigurent etc aujourd'hui après 40 ans
de décentralisation de la plupart des
compétences de l'aménagement c'est à
dire le logement les mobilités la
gestion de
la citoyenneté locale etc on peut plus
réfléchir de cette manière avec une
vision par le haut de ce que devrait
être la france dans 50 ans pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est que la france est dans l'europe un
maillon de l'europe et que autant sur
les questions strictement de relation
usager le territoire peut être une main
utile autant sur les questions
économiques en jeu c'est bien le marché
européen est celui dans lequel se situe
les outils de régulation
la france seule dans le monde n'a pas ne
jouent pas de rôle ou en tout cas ne
peut pas jouer un rôle important à
l'échelle de l'économie évidemment
complètement mondialisée donc faut
arriver à un briquet cette logique de
planification à la fois dans cette
grande échelle européenne avec une
brique nationale française est dans la
réalité de ce qu'est aujourd'hui
l'aménagement du territoire qui est très
largement portés par les collectivités
locales les régions notamment sur le
développement économique évidemment les
villes intercommunalité sur tout ce qui
relève de l'environnement bâti de
l'environnement vécu et puis je dirais
plus largement cette notion de
territoire qui est un peu flou il faut
aussi l'entendre avec des acteurs
économiques des citoyens des
associations locales des protecteurs de
l'environnement comme des entités
universitaires qui font elles-mêmes
vivre une économie et une société locale
et c'est en partant de l'articulation
entre ces territoires et leur capacité à
produire et à être une contribution au
projet national est en croissance et
avec des filières qu'on peut
éventuellement réalisés à l'échelle
française ou européenne contre la
logique de planification et au cynisme
c'est en somme tout est dans tout mais
alors jean hervé lorenzi vous êtes
économiste et vous l'êtes depuis un
certain temps donc vous avez le
privilège de l'expérience qu'est ce que
ça vous fait que le mot planification
reviennent à la mode parce que pendant
un certain temps disait ne parlons plus
de ça c'est du néo marxistes mais et c
est là on n'entend plus que ça
aujourd'hui d'abord ça me fait plaisir
parce que je suis fais partie ce qui est
logiquement ont toujours pensé qu'il
allait essayer planifier le monde
planifiez ça signifie pas oublié comment
créer des gosses plan des dispositifs
soient dispositif j'ai totalement
impératif ya des incitations j'ai pensé
qu'il valait mieux construire son avenir
manière rationnelle que de laisser le
marché où les évolutions très court
terme deuxième remarque sur la question
des territoires ddt un mot un peu
général un peu floue reconnaître que
territoire ça veut tout dire et rien
dire la réalité c'est que il ya un vrai
clivage idéologique
en france on va rester deux noms sur le
système français en france y est les
girondins et les et les jacobins moi je
suis plutôt du côté des girondins les
girondins quand j'étais jeune on regarde
et l'autogestion yougoslave qui était
quand même quand j'ai réfléchi assez
surréaliste avec admiration parce que
c'était l'idée que le pouvoir d'autres
s'exprimer de manière la plus proche
possible un individu ça c'est de
l'idéologie position
et puis il y avait il ya le ce que
disent les économistes
objectivement sur ce thème là ils disent
on était pas grand chose ils disent
alors ils travaillent ils ont travaillé
sur ce qu'on appelle les agglomérations
c'est l'idée qu'on est plus fort quand
on regroupe par l'endroit mettons à
dunkerque on regroupe des tas
d'activités qui se nourrissent les unes
les autres permettent de de finalement
matière de formation termeer c'est ce
qu'on appelle les clusters donc me
clusters et parents présents le détail
par la l voilà c'est les crachats et
puis il ya l'idée assez inverse que le
marché plus il est grand ces idées la
mondialisation c'est même l'idée de
l'europe plus il est grand plus ça
bougeait plus meilleur c'est parce que
ça fait baisser les coûts selon
s'aperçoit c'est que ça ne marche pas
été renvoyée donc donc la réponse entre
saint lô planification c'est un peu
régulé un capitalisme qui est trop
libéral dans quelques cents c'est pas
réguler le capitaine mais c'est une
formulation j'aime pas bien le mot
régulation parce que je trouve qu'il
veut rien dire j'aime bien le mot
construire et le moc once de planifier
ça veut dire qu'on construit son avenir
sans pour autant se transformer en des
soviétiques barbare et est effrayant on
se dit voilà où je veux aller et voilà
comment quels sont les moyens et vous
connaissez et je termine là dessus la
définition d'économie la théorie
économique c'est l'allocation des
ressources rares et donc on alloue les
ressources sera en fonction de l'endroit
où on veut aller je trouve que c'est
plus malin que de dire on se contente de
regarder ce qui se passe et puis
advienne que pourra très bien alors
maintenant on passe à l'aménagement du
territoire on a la chance d'avoir deux
élus de ville intéressante et importante
dijon et dunkerque alors monsieur
rebsamen la france est plutôt
bonapartiste colbertiste ça a été
rappelé est ce que on est quand même
très différent de l'allemagne des länder
est ce que vous pensez qu'on
pourra réussir un aménagement des
territoires en france et qu'est ce que
serait pour vous je poserai la même
question à votre collègue un véritable
ministère de l'aménagement des
territoires
moi je veux bien qu'on parle de
l'aménagement des territoires je veux
bien qu'on parle des territoires mais
j'aimerais qu'on précise la notion de
territoire a été évoquée tout de suite
tout le monde dit territoire aujourd'hui
mais finalement ça ne veut plus rien
dire
les villes sont des villes les campagnes
sont des campagnes les agglomérations
sont des agglomérations les régions sont
des régions et tout le monde dit les
territoires ce qui permet finalement de
ne pas traiter les problèmes moi je vais
parler d'une manière administrative
d'abord avant de rentrer sur
l'interaction qui doit exister
indéniablement entre l'impulsion
nationale et l'impulsion locales et
comment elles peuvent à un moment où pas
se rencontrer ce vous interrogerez après
précisément sur dijon et sur ma mère je
réponds pas sur des gens voilà j'avais
pas sur des gens j'ai bien compris moi
je moi je considère que aujourd'hui
notre pays est pénalisé par
l'administration territoriale de la
république dont nous disposons et je
pose la question administrative dans un
premier temps avant de poser un question
des interactions qui peuvent exister je
dis que nous devons revoir
l'administration territoriale de la
république c'est à dire l'organisation
et donc il y as pour moi d des espaces
aujourd'hui à occuper manière
intelligente sans tomber dans le
clientélisme et en développant des idées
assez simple il ya les villes et les
regroupements de communes dans les
villes autour des villes les
agglomérations les communautés urbaines
les métropoles tant décriée et pourtant
tant créatrice de richesse pour notre
pays et puis il ya des départements où
subsiste quelques au broc qui sont en
général des clientéliste et qui se
nourrissent du clientélisme sur leur
propre territoire ils sont élus même si
ces territoires vote front national ça
ne dérange absolument pas ils véhiculent
à 80% pas tous bien évidemment je ne
généralise pas mais ça existe il
véhicule une et misérabiliste du des
territoires sur lesquels ils sont élus
c'est toujours plus pauvre qu'ailleurs
c'est toujours moins bien lotis
qu'ailleurs et donc finalement ils se
complaisent dedans pour être et moi je
suis pour la suppression de l'élection
des dd des conseillers départementaux et
je suis pour que il ya une assemblée des
départements départementale qui soit
composé des représentants des
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale ça on aurait au moins une
petite perspective d'aménagement des
départements autrement nous avons
aujourd'hui non pas des causses et
départementaux mais des cantonniers et
donc voilà après il ya les régions donc
on pourrait parler d'une nouvelle
organisation les régions elles ont été
faites sur un bout de papier on a
ressorti sûrement chaire économistes on
a ressorti j'en suis sûr les vieux
documents du plan où on disait à
l'époque dans les années 60-70 ce qu'il
fallait douze ou treize régions
le président de la république de
l'époque a dû se dire ça doit bien
exister quelque part il a essayé de le
reformuler sa avec l'idée que je ne
pense pas juste qu'ils avaient gagné les
esprits c'est que pour être fort il faut
être grand or je considère qu' il ya des
territoires qui sont très forts sans
être de grands territoires je dire de
grands espaces territoriaux et donc il
faudrait revoir tout ça pour permettre à
ces vies à ces agglomérations à ces
départements à ces régions de porter des
véritables politiques les mois juste une
seconde vous critiquer ces grandes
régions qui pour certains d'entre elles
qui sont à eux difformes oui bien sûr
qu'une ressemble à rien il ne ressemble
à rien nous on la voit donc je pense
qu'il faudrait d'ailleurs permettent de
les redessiner notre sujet est pour moi
de décider de sa main puisqu'on parle de
sage oui je considère et en plus elles
sont souvent antinomiques à part la
haute et la basse normandie vraiment
y avait beaucoup de choses à faire et
donc si on arrivait à avoir des
territoires qui portent mieux une partie
de l'intérêt général des régions des
départements et des villes et autres eh
bien nous pourrions avoir une meilleure
interaction avec un niveau national qui
doit impulser et qui doit rencontrer à
un moment qui doit rencontrer tout ce
qui se passe sur dans nos villes jeu par
reprendre le mot territoire ça dans nos
villes dans nos départements et dont
elle est dans nos régions c'est ça
finalement la nouvelle planification
c'est de permettre la rencontre entre la
volonté politique nationale de créer par
exemple une une filière et puis je on
peut voir on pourra prendre des exemples
qu'on va en parler à prendre elle une
très simple très simplement l'hydrogène
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un vrai sujet
mais on en parle beaucoup mais c'est sur
le territoire c'est dans les villes et
dans les territoires que ça se passe et
pourtant il n'ya pas encore
l'interaction qui devrait y avoir donc
voilà d'abord une réforme administrative
et puis après on pourra avancer plus de
manière plus structurée mathieu maire
greek sur l'aménagement du territoire
qu'est ce qui est à faire qu'est ce qui
est à défaire d'abord je me réjouis
qu'on parle à nouveau d'aménagement du
territoire parce que ça fait presque 40
ans qu'en france on a abandonné toute
idée d'aménagement du territoire donc
moi je me réjouis aujourd'hui c'est un
mot qui revient à la mode et et tant
mieux voilà tant mieux pour deux raisons
essentielles d'abord parce qu'il y a des
problèmes dans notre pays d'égalité
d'accès à un certain nombre de grands
services publics je viens d'un coeur
qu'un dans l'égalité d'accès aux soins
par exemple l'égalité d'accès à
l'hôpital l'éducation donc tout toutes
ces questions là elle est vraiment
fondamental aujourd'hui il faut la
remettre sur la table je pense que la
crise des gilet jaune s'explique aussi
par une forme de sentiment d'inégalité
par rapport aux grands services publics
nationaux et puis la deuxième raison
c'est que se pose aussi la question de
l'égalité des chances de développement
des territoires donc compense une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
sur ces deux éléments là me paraît
plutôt aller dans le bon sens après je
rejoins un peu la discussion vous avez
eues on va peut-être chercher des mots
d'il ya 40 ans pour le faire et ça
peut-être que les concepts sont un peu
usés moi le mot planification c'est pas
que je n'aime pas c'est je le trouve
date est en fait en réalité et est
aujourd'hui
la politique d'aménagement du territoire
qu'il faut penser n'a plus rien à voir
avec celle des années 80 où des années
70 aujourd'hui les territoires
je pourrais pour dire sur ce qui a dit
françois rebsamen sur les territoires
pour moi c'est essentiellement
intercommunalités c'est le bloc communal
quoi ces communes et intercommunalités
c'est là pour moi le coeur des
territoires et je rejoins ce qui a été
dit sur les institutions mais il y a
aujourd'hui dans la population a besoin
de sens et je pense que les politiques
nationales ont du mal à donner du sens à
la population les maires finalement les
présidents d'intercommunalités sont
mieux placés pour expliquer les
changements les transitions qui sont en
cours il ya besoin de différenciation
moi je vis des lois qui sont adaptées
pour un accident en charente-maritime
qu'on applique sur un polder chez moi
qui sont totalement inadaptés totalement
inadapté la population qui voit ça ne
comprends pas un autre exemple au moment
de la crise sanitaire on met en place
des mesures qui sont les mêmes pour une
plage qui fait 140 kilomètres carrés une
plage qui fait 10 mètres carrés et c'est
les mêmes mesures la population ne
comprend pas il ya plus de sens donc
sans différenciation il n'y a plus de
sens et enfin dernier élément qui
justifie une politique d'aménagement du
territoire repensé par les territoires
et non pas de manière descendante c'est
le silo aujourd'hui l'état ne sait
fonctionner quand ce silo quand
injonction par silos c'est l'injonction
transports c'est l'injonction
inondations c'est l'injonction là or la
ville durable les enjeux de transition
c'est des enjeux transversaux par
essence et l'état ne sait pas faire ça
ou alors le meilleur communal c'est le
fin jean hervé lorenzi vous avez entendu
deux élus territoriaux dire que les a
besoin d'aménager le territoire
est ce qu'à votre avis il faut un
ministère de l'aménagement du territoire
même si c'est faire retour avec une
sémantique manciet jauger les mots je
suis parent malade et vous j'aime bien
et je retire même le mot planification
je le mets construction ont construit
son avenir je je trouve ça qui pour un
homme qui n'est pas tout jeune comme moi
c'est le message a passé haut la
jeunesse et que ce qui est intéressant
dans l'existence de bâtir seulement sa
propre sa propre trajectoire alors est
ce qu'il faut faire un ministère moi
j'en sais rien
si vous me le proposait je répondrais
oui c'est pour vous pour vous même bien
sûr bien sûr mais si sinon je suis
convaincu que ce qui nous va une des
choses qui ne va pas dans le pays c'est
que les il faut trouver le connecteur
à laquelle les bonnes questions sur
l'histoire de de l'apprentissage il ya
eu beaucoup de discussions et c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai que ça donnait qu'un
bon résultat changement de d'acteur
jouant un rôle positif il ya des tas de
domaines notamment par exemple le sujet
de la réindustrialisation je suis
convaincu que c'est la région où lé ou
le l'agglomération ou qui portent parce
qu'il sent ce qu'il faut faire là je
retrouve mes petits de théorie
économique
le cluster l'idée que lorsqu'on
rassemble des gens qui ont réédité en
matière de formation matière
d'investissements arrive finalement à
ceux à se renforcer dans les autres ça
c'est positif et ça se fait pas au
niveau au niveau national pour aller
dans le sens de ce que vous venez dire
c'est vrai que j'habite tout près enfin
j'habite pour partie tout près d'une
ville qui avait été créée au monde avait
créé les jeux plus combien il avait
civile autour de paris nous y voilà
c'est totalement inadapté aujourd'hui
avoir à créer des villes et il faut
redonner sûrement à chaque acteur est
évidemment à l'acteur on va dire pas
territoriale je suis comme toi je pense
que le territoire local là la capacité
d'agir qui est 2 avec la perception le
nom fait des erreurs ou si c'est la vie
ça mais quand même il ya moins d'erreurs
qui est fait par pas besoin de dire pour
vous ad par le patron dijon du patron de
dunkerque que par un fonctionnaire qui
est
installé
modestement d'ailleurs souvent dans un
ministère quelconque moyennant quoi
jacques c'est quand même la proposition
de mystère et maison territoire
[Musique]
et l peskine on vient de voir la
citation de bruno latour le politique ne
peut pas tout à votre avis aujourd'hui
qui
est en position
d'avoir le meilleur avis pour gouverner
un territoire surtout que le territoire
est devenu un personnel avec le
numérique pour revenir ce que disait
jean hervé lorenzi je vais utiliser un
mot à la mode mais je crois vraiment
c'est plus que construction ses co
construction on a absolument besoin que
cette planification ce projet national
qui est aussi le projet de société pour
le territoire france soit qu'on
construit avec tous ceux qui agissent
tattoo leur niveau et c'est pour ça que
je redis qu'on peut pas croire qu'une
seule personne d'un seul endroit en
france fut-il très brillant très
intelligent et très informé arrivera à
définir comment vont atterrir toutes les
politiques publiques toutes les actions
territoriales selon qu'on est sur le
littoral à la montagne dans une
métropole dans une ruralité éloigné à la
montagne et qu'on subit pas du tout de
la même manière les effets et des
grandes transformations du monde si on
parle de planification écologique on va
s'intéresser par exemple à la neutralité
carbone là comment est-ce qu'on va
baisser deux émissions de gaz à effet de
serre demain grands enjeux de ce
j'imagine de cet objectif de
planification évidemment qu'à dunkerque
où les émissions de gaz à effet serre
sont excessivement importante compte
tenu de l'histoire industrielle de ce
territoire on n'aura pas la même logique
territoriale qu'à dijon où c'est pas
forcément le cas de kayes peur d'eux
dans un jeu et notamment une
appropriation des questions alimentaires
territoriales qui sont particulièrement
intense importante dans ce territoire
historiquement reconnue pour sa
viticulture son agriculture etc et donc
il est absolument essentiel à mon avis
qu'on arrive à décrire comment chacun
d'eux ces blocs territoriaux
effectivement je sois que c'est beaucoup
à l'échelle intercommunale que ça va se
passer mais il ya quand même
certainement un rôle d'organisation
peut-être de là que pour le niveau
régional notamment des filières
économiques et de la formation comment
chacun de ces blocs territoriaux va
vivre cette transition compte tenu des
objectifs qu'on est tous aujourd'hui
contraint de partager il faut baisser
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
faut réduire les inégalités sociales et
territoriales
il faut faire face à la mondialisation
et apprivoiser le numérique voilà en
gros ce sont les quatre grands enjeux
auquel chacun est confronté aujourd'hui
consent chefs d'entreprise comme ça un
habitué combien coordination entre ces
cas une coordination entre ses
différentes activités
moi je pour co-construire il ya besoin
quand même d'une le numérique n'est pas
ne peut pas se substituer à la
gouvernance on a un gros défaut en
france c'est qu'on ne se fait pas
confiance entre les uns et les autres on
n'a pas de confiance règne entre l'état
et les collectivités l'état avec le
levier fiscal décide ou non si la
collectivité a bien fait son travail
alors qu'elle lui a dédié toutes les
compétences délivrer toutes les
compétences pour agir on a pas de
confiance même au niveau local pas
toujours entre les pouvoirs publics et
les partenaires privés ou les seconds
citoyens socia tiff alors beaucoup de
mal à se partager finalement le la
réalisation des objectifs qui sont
encore une fois auquel tout le monde
doit doit se confronter donc je ne sais
pas dire exactement sous quelle forme il
faudra le faire est ce que cette
magnifique à sion va se traduire en
contrats territoriaux ce qui est
important c'est qu'on évite d'avoir
cette logique très descendante qui est
très classique en france même quand on
prétend donner des compétences de
politiques publiques aux collectivités
territoriales en réalité on contrôle on
régule beaucoup parlent devoir fiscal
qui est très faible niveau local par la
fiscalité incitative qui est certes un
territoire où certaines filières et pas
les autres etc il faut arriver à
construire avec le territoire donné
mettons dunkerque la manière dont la
fiscalité et les subventions publiques
vont aider européennes et nationales
vont aider un territoire comme celui là
à sortir de sa très forte dépendance au
carbone et de ses modèles économiques
vous a entendu alors sur mesure rebsamen
vous avez été ministre vous êtes élu
vous avez 2 une responsabilité sur la
question de l'emploi est ce que les
territoires sont en mesure en quelque
sorte d'apporter un souffle si je puis
dire à la création d'emplois à travers
des emplois qualifiés à travers
l'apprentissage la part des territoires
sur l'emploi comment vous la voyez
l'emploi il il est dans les villes il
est dans les régions c'est là que se
crée l'activité c'est là que tu es
positionner l'activité économique c'est
là que se déroule l'activité économique
et c'est là que sont les emplois et donc
c'est tout ça par part du local c'est le
cas de le dire est que ce soit ne
retrouve pas l'emploi
l'emploi nécessaire et qualifiés dans du
local on a quelquefois besoin de voir
plus loin il ya d'autres il ya d'autres
territoires qui sont prêts à compenser
est ce que disait tout à l'heure patrice
vérité c'est tout à fait juste
aujourd'hui par notre histoire
centralisatrice on ne reconnaît pas le
droit à la différence de nos territoires
et donc de nos villes je parlais des
villes comme ça on comprendra mieux de
nos villes on nous intercalerons on ne
on ne nous donne pas le droit d'être
différent des zones et pourtant dijon
est différente dunkerque et les règles
nationales ça pose de la même manière et
en plus elles descendent sous la forme
d'appel à projets quoi qu'on nous fait
alors qu'elle devrait remonter en
partant des projets que nous nous
portons c'est très difficile à faire
comprendre à ceux qui dirigent au niveau
national quel que soit ce qui dirige
d'ailleurs
donc on a cette nécessité de reconnaître
les différences et de laisser plus de
place à l'initiative privée privés et
publics dans les territoires dans les
villes pour pour près de l'école
activité économique pour se développer
que d'attendre que nous viennent du
national des dépositions qui seront
uniforme sur l'ensemble du territoire et
qui pénalise sur l'ensemble du
territoire national on peut parler du
territoire national et qui pénalisent
celles et ceux qui au porteur
d'initiatives tout à fait original et
qui peuvent se compléter ici ou là
d'ailleurs sur tel ou tel sujet une
filière par exemple etc ça nous renvoie
aux clusters dont parlait jean hervé
lorenzi tout à l'heure et je voudrais je
voudrais ajouter quand on regarde bien
les choses il y a je crois une nécessité
aujourd'hui pour associer la population
à ce qui va être le grand défi qui nous
attend à savoir la lutte contre le
changement climatique contre le
réchauffement climatique
il faut absolument que les scientifiques
nous fournissent des outils des
expertises d' analyse et dont le public
pourra s'approprier que le public pourra
s'approprier on nous dit diminuer vos
gaz à effet de serre bon pour le citoyen
lambda excusez moi ça veut pas dire
grand chose il comprend il regarde un
peu la télé comprendre où il a garé son
ordi il comprend à peu près ce que ça
veut dire mais il n'a pas d'indicateur
or moi je suis pour que sur thur ces
thèmes là on est des indicateurs précis
qui prennent en compte les différences
c'est vrai que la situation n'est pas du
tout la même par exemple dans nos deux
villes et pour autant nous au niveau
local on peut se donner des objectifs
qui sont des objectifs de réduction par
exemple si on prend des gaz à effet de
serre ou l'augmentation de d'énergie
renouvelable propre au niveau d'une
ville par exemple qui sont différentes
suivant les villes mais si on nous dit à
tous il faut augmenter votre part
d'énergie renouvelable sans nous dire
comment on peut fixer des choses que les
gens comprennent les gens ils adhèrent
quand ils comprennent et quand on en
fait des acteurs eux-mêmes à on essaye
on apprend on a commencé tout bêtement
dire consommer moins d'eau alors vous
fermez vos robinets quand vous voulez
aller dans des trucs comme ça mais ça ça
ne ça ne parle pas autrement que par un
petit exemple on devrait pouvoir
afficher partout dans toutes les villes
des grands objectifs et on devrait
pouvoir les évaluer ce récit référé voir
si on échoue ce qui peut arriver voir si
on réussit et partager ses expériences
et mal justement sur ces emplois
industriels tout ça créera deux l'emploi
de monsieur vers great une quelle
impulsion territoriale il peut y avoir
pour combler ce recul des emplois
industriels au lait en particulier
l'emploi industriel est un bon exemple
des transitions le le prix parce qu'il
est un refus évident mais c'est un bon
exemple des transitions qu'on est en
train de vivre je veux vraiment illustré
on a vécu et où on sort plutôt je trouve
d'une période qui a duré plusieurs
décennies de gestion du chômage faut le
dire c'était la gestion de la file
d'attenté
quand on a la gestion du chômage
finalement qu'est-ce qui jouent la
solidarité entre les actifs et la
solidarité nationale et donc on avait
des acteurs qui correspondait à ces
solidarités on change d'air on change
d'époque c'est le cas par exemple à
dunkerque chez moi l'emploi industriel
repart à macaq est fortement il ya des
milliers de créations d'emplois
industriels la problématique maintenant
dans les industries dunkerquoise c'est
plus chômage c'est la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on rentre dans une nouvelle
époque la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
hélas le territoire redevient centrale
pourquoi et d'ailleurs on a fait une
réunion récemment avec l'éducation
nationale où j'ai beaucoup insisté là
dessus j'ai demandé à titre expérimental
que la communauté urbaine de dunkerque
prenne la compétence orientation la
communauté urbaine théoriquement n'a pas
de compétences autour de l'orientation
professionnelle j'ai souhaité à titre
expérimental prendre cette compétence
accompagner les jeunes lorsque sont les
métiers faire connaître les métiers de
l'industrie je pense que ce serait mieux
fait aujourd'hui par les territoires
donc en l'occurrence chez moi les
agglomérations est ce on se met d'accord
ici ce que tu as appelé les villes
françois et je pense aujourd'hui que
dans cette nouvelle ère de l'emploi de
l'emploi industriel en particulier les
territoires où beaucoup plus à jouer
orientation accompagnement dans la
formation
attractivité même pour ceux qui
n'habitent pas le territoire qui
pourrait demain venir s'y installer qui
est ce qui va aider un habitant à venir
s'installer dans le dunkerquois s'il ya
des métiers du sahel et si et si
effectivement il n'est pas du territoire
dunkerquois c'est la communauté urbaine
assez pas l'état c'est pas les d'akiva
qui va très mal logement qui va
accompagner l'emploi du conjoint qui
voit là je pense que les territoires
aujourd'hui dans le monde de l'emploi
qui est en train d'émerger honda rôle
beaucoup plus important à jouer que par
le boss m'a alors jarre vélo vannes si
on vient d'écouter deux élus qui disent
que les territoires peuvent jouer un
rôle sur l'emploi mais au niveau de la
réindustrialisation
les pôles de compétitivité sont
importants est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut laisser ça aux territoires c'est à
dire favoriser l'émergence de pôles de
compétitivité pour réindustrialiser le
pays est ce que la marque d'autonomie
que peut avoir le territoire sur ce
sujet capital d'abord je suis avant tout
à fait d'accord avec ce que dit le maire
de dunkerque je veux juste qu'on hayatou
qui veut plus précisément sur le sujet
pourquoi la france et de dance réaliser
ça s'est passé au niveau national ça
s'est passé sur l'idée simple que ma
génération
ils sont pas si loin que ça de cette
génération là en tout cas françois et à
penser que dans les 30 dernières années
que l'avenir du pays c'était un avenir
qui était enceinte dans les services et
donc qu'on vous ait du tourisme de ceci
et de cela est que ce pays très
fondamentalement industriels car il faut
quand même savoir que la france est un
pays très industrielle au départ n'avait
plus besoin de faire ça donc on a les
grandes entreprises françaises ont des
lequel faisait plus que n'importe quelle
autre entreprise
enfin c'est toute une histoire avec une
responsabilité des grands économistes
qui on dira aussi que il fallait passer
aux services oui oui tout le monde a sa
part de responsabilité le monde a sa
part de s'inviter mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que le thème est
devenu à était idéologiquement en france
puis à la france est un cas unique
je rappelle juste pour ceux qui
l'auraient oublié que dans les 27 pays
de l'union européenne la france et 26e
en termes de pourcentage tombe à genoux
je me réjouisse la bombe à la grèce mais
à part la grèce on est le pays qui a le
pourcentage le plus faible de tous les
pays de l'union européenne en termes de
d'emplois industriels par leurs proches
et à tous c'est hallucinant ce qui s'est
passé s'il sera incroyable la
désindustrialisation française est c'est
fait idéologiquement haut niveau
euh là j'allais dire du territoire
français de la même manière que quand on
dit on va rien disque réalisé l'europe
je me dis on devrait d'abord traiter le
problème français avant de vouloir
réaliser l'allemagne qui au fond ne nous
a pas attendu pour avoir une industrie
assez forte de tout ça est quand même
jalili est historiquement et
géographiquement daté et précis a part
ça la réalisation keita une chemin
difficile
évidemment il y a des grands projets
d'innovation se fait quand même je vais
dire avec beaucoup d'argent donc mais là
s'il ya des tas de choses qui vont se
faire au niveau je l'espère européen
c'est ce que thierry breton lance avec
d'ailleurs des ampleurs d'investissement
encore très largement insuffisante par
rapport à ce que font les chinois et
américains il ya des tas de choses qui
vont se faire en france d'hydrogène ça a
été évoqué où il ya des domaines où on
est très bon et franchement côté les
allemands sont très bons ils partagent
pas tellement avec nous quand même pas
être trop naïve sur ces sujets et puis
il ya énormément de sujets l'éducation
ce que vous avez dit l'éducation le
l'orientation le l'impulsion doit être
fait au niveau est ce que vous diriez de
la ville c'était lorenzi est ce que vous
diriez que réindustrialiser la france
c'est aussi améliorer le pouvoir d'achat
parce que c'est apporter plus de
prospérité est-ce que ça a un rapport
direct bien sûr mais il ya un chiffre
qu'il faut pas
vous oubliez
dans les biens manufacturés que nous
achetons en euros les frigides bayonne
38 % rendez compte 36 % simplement s'en
produit en france on est un pays qui a
vécu une histoire il imaginable le
l'effondrement d'industrie française
c'est unique je prends toujours un sens
en sens inverse lorsque ont noté des au
début du 20e siècle lorsqu'on est dans
le tout le coin qui aujourd'hui la
défense a l'air plutôt etc il y avait 2
127 petit atelier qui fabriquait des
bagnoles c'est à dire que la voiture
elle est née là elle aimait il à cet
endroit là et puis on avait secoué ce
goût et puis on la perd vue c'est comme
ça c'est l'histoire - j'ai le sentiment
qu'on est en train de de le retrouver à
travers ce que vous indiquez c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de création d'emplois
avec ma conception c'est qu'il faut pas
trop se concentrer sur la relocalisation
de bien banalisé et plutôt investir dans
des sujets qui sont tes sujets d'avenir
ou des stratégies pas savoir faire du
vaccin pas savoir faire en vous as c'est
pas quand même temps on vous a entendu
lnp ce qui ne nous entendait le discours
la
réindustrialisation peut redonner de
nouveau souffle à la france est ce que
vous pensez même si le raccourci est
trop grand est-ce que vous pensez que
cette désindustrialisation
un rapport quelque part avec les
territoires d'abandon les filets jaunes
d'exeter alors d'abord voudrait peut
prolonger la discussion inquiet qui est
vraiment intéressante parce que on a
commencé en parlant de planification en
fait ce qu'on se dit lassé que même si
on appelait pas planification depuis
trente ans la planification france sur
le projet stratégique national a détruit
des emplois et la détruit beaucoup
d'emplois dans tout un tas de territoire
qui se sont trouvées démunies je pense
aux collectivités locales notamment
métropole pour les maintenir parce que
finalement elle était inscrite dans un
système très mondialisé de
relocalisation délocalisations et quand
je dis on a détruit des emplois c'est
notamment des sociétés dans lesquelles
l'état est actionnaire en particulier
dans l'automobile par exemple on à
délocaliser massivement des emplois qui
pourtant faisait vite des territoires et
je trouve que c'est un peu hypocrite de
penser qu'avec la planification
maintenant désormais on va réussir à
réinvestir cette question d'emploi dans
le territoire alors que comme ça a été
très bien illustré c'est plutôt les
collectivités locales aujourd'hui se bat
pour être introduire de l'emploi
qualitatif effectivement qualifiés dans
les bonnes filières sur les différents
territoires et je trouve que les deux
exemples de dunkerque exigences sont
particulièrement intéressants parce que
ces deux territoires
pour les élus il n'en parlera mieux que
moi mais sont très investis sur
justement les filières d'avenir de leur
territoire d'un côté autour de grands
acteurs économiques de la métallurgie
casse aller à dunkerque qui lui-même
s'implique dans la transformation des
emplois notamment via le numérique
autour de laboratoire à terme de
transformation des emplois qui donkey
comment dire qu'ils planifient justement
l'organisation de son territoire en
matière économique ou ou dijon autour de
la cité de la gastronomie et de tout un
projet territorial qui tourne autour du
set aussi de ses politiques publiques
qui ont du sens donc en parler de perte
du sens mais justement c'est parce que
les élus locaux connaissent bien leur
territoire qui peuvent donner du sens on
répondre à votre question sur sur la
réindustrialisation alors bon c'est bon
un peu là aussi un peu valises dans
lequel on sait pas très bien ce qu'on me
lâche me donner un exemple de
construction vous lisiez mais est ce
qu'on peut vraiment décidé depuis le
territoire des ce qui est bon pour
l'avenir de la france en partie oui mais
on peut peut-être le décider ensemble
avec une vision nationale ou européenne
qui permette de trouver les bons moyens
financiers pour y arriver ou les bonnes
stratégies territoriales et on a un
exemple la récent qui est la politique
des territoires d'industrie en france
qu'il politique nationale dans le cadre
de la cohésion des territoires porté par
le gouvernement qui cherche à retrouver
des vocations à des territoires
historiquement industrielle plutôt des
villes moyennes parce que c'était là
qu'était développé des tissus
industriels et qui désormais s'accroche
à la stratégie france 2030 qui lie les
sept grandes filières aéronautique
automobile en espérant qu'elles sont un
peu décarbonés
santé évidemment voilà qui sont et
agroalimentaire qui sont les grands
succès
elle de la france qui doivent trouver
leur place dans cette revitalisation des
territoires d'industrie dangla sûr qu'on
a une logique intelligente on a un
projet national qui fait sens avec donc
encore une fois un choix stratégique des
filières dans lesquelles on note des
savoir faire et un atterrissage comme
dit bruno latour sur des terrains qui
sont capables ou en tout cas qui
pourraient être capables demain si on
leur donne les moyens de développer les
emplois qui correspondent à ces finir
[Musique]
monsieur rebsamen les territoires vous
l'avez mentionné n'ont pas vraiment de
frontières il ya des villes et
communautés urbaines ya le l'urbain et
le rural etc tout ça constitue un
carrefour d'inter territorialité avec
des échanges est ce que la
digitalisation temps par le temps
aujourd'hui
favorise vraiment la coopération intra
interterritoriale et même au niveau
national il faut déjà qu'elle commence à
exister aurait elle se fait au niveau
des entreprises se fait plus
difficilement dans la relation entre
collectivités donc commençons par parler
des villes intelligentes que nous sommes
en train de créer notamment de dijon
alors je parlerai des gens je parle de
ma ville bien sûr mais d'autres peuvent
en parler aussi de leur ville bien
évidemment donc à dijon nous avons créé
nous avons supprimé tous les six lots
dont dont tu parlais tout à l'heure et
donc nous avons une politique
transversale qui est dirigé par le
numérique à travers un pôle central
connectés qui fait que tout l'espace
public aujourd'hui est connecté à ce
pôle central est donc tout le pôle
public c'est à dire la boirie la
sécurité la santé l'éclairage tout tout
tout tout c'est pas du jour au lendemain
évidemment là trente six mille fois
l'une est à dire que ces bouilles ouais
super et cetera tout est concentré on
n'a pas besoin d'aller aller chercher à
côté on va commencer pied en moins
on va commencer par le commencement
comment faire le sens au niveau de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
changeons les 36000 poids lumineux
faisons 36000 l'aide et connectons ses
36 miled un point central où on pourra
moduler et faire des économies de
consommation etc et créer de l'emploi
autour de ça bien évidemment donc nous
sommes très allants sur cette ville
intelligente et d'ailleurs on est
reconnu comme tel après il faut que ça
se développe et que ça continue à
progresser mais je voudrais prendre un
exemple précis pour montrer les
difficultés que des collectivités plein
de bonnes intentions des villes veulent
rencontre quand elles veulent se
réindustrialiser ou industrialisés sur
une filière naissante je parlais de
l'hydrogène ça mérite deux minutes je
vous en prie allez-y nous voulons être
la première ville française à équiper
toute notre flotte de transport en
commun et de bennes à ordures ménagères
à l'hydrogène c'est financé par l'europe
ça attendez vous allez voir vous allez
être surpris de deux de l'hydrogène que
nous fournissons nous mêmes donc nous
nous sommes dit il faut un électrolyseur
donc où l entreprise qui fournit des
électrolyseurs n'a pas beaucoup il y en
a une pour le moment on achète
l'électrolyseur et puis on va commencer
à acheter des bennes à ordures ménagères
qui vont fonctionner dès cette année à
l'hydrogène et puis des bus où on fait
des bus à hydrogène en un petit début de
création industrielle à albi mais c'est
très difficile sur pas beaucoup soutenu
et pour créer une filière il faut que le
gouvernement c'est-à-dire faut que
l'état décide de mettre le paquet pour
accompagner les premières créations
parce que c'est uniquement par
l'augmentation du nombre qu'on arrivera
à créer un circuit et donc je regarde et
nous sommes plafonné dans nos aides à
40% toi tu le sais nous somme plafonnée
à 40 % le premier ministre vient je lui
présente tout ce qu'on fait et j'essaie
d'aller vite et et
et je lui dis mais pourquoi nous somme
plafonnée à 40 % et bliss l europe pas
plus de 40% du plafond de subventions
pour aider à la création de cette
filière ah bon et jeudi et pourquoi en
allemagne c'est 80% et il me dit c'est
pas vieux est ce que je raconte et il me
dit bon c'est 80 % en allemagne car
c'est à dire l'état donne 40 % en france
et 80 % en allemagne pas que l'état
l'état les régions
le maximum de subventions autorisée en
france c'est 40 % par l'europe et ses 80
% en allemagne il ne le savait pas et
donc qui me dit et il me dit ah ça alors
là alors là ça me surprend je je me
renseigne il était très très bien il se
renseigne seront ils me renvoient un
papier un petit mot le lendemain matin
tu as raison incroyable j'active
l'europe tout de suite voilà des
exemples où nous moi je sais depuis un
moment que en allemagne c'est 80% et
nous c'est 40 % mais au niveau de l'état
personne ne donc comment voulez vous
créer des filières que vous n'avez pas
dead au même niveau que d'autres
d'autres pays pour pour développer une
filière naissante riche pour l'avenir
productrice et créatrice d'emplois
assurément qui va en plus dans le sens
de la transition est ce que vous avez
fait avec andy jean cette plateforme
numérique formidable est-ce que
sincèrement oui les usagers sont
contents pour les usagers et ça commence
parce que ce que nous avons décidé c'est
maintenant de mettre ce qu'on appelle le
hall à disposition du public oui alors
ça veut dire que un citoyen dans un coin
d'une ville de la ville qui voit je
prends n'importe quel exemple une
ampoule cassé il pianote sur son
portable en poule k c'est rude il envoie
sa est normalement dans l'après midi
même c'est réparé et donc on a ainsi
cassé donc tous les to les silos parce
qu'avant il fallait appeler la mairie
qui appelait l'électricien qui veillait
c'est une entreprise d'électricité la
part la part la rupture de style autant
que vous êtes en train de dire c'est que
le citoyen à dijon et pas qu'à dijon
dans l'ensemble de la communauté
à travers cette plate forme il peut
trouver chaussure à son pied pour toutes
ses activités sur la voie publique sur
la voie publique public sur les wii sur
la bible il veut il veut une place de
stationnement il regarde sur son
portable et puis on lui dit où il ya une
place de stationnement on va on lui
répond alors évidemment ça panique le
maire quand ça commence ouais je me dis
est-ce qu'on va être en état de répondre
à toutes les demandes donc je ne fais
pas trop de publicité au début ça
commence depuis le mois de novembre fin
novembre bon ça fait trois mois j'ai eu
des élections donc on ne parle que moi
tant mieux mais on va relancer il faut
que les citoyens seulement par robert
amard vraiment à dunkerque c'est dans un
autre domaine que vous avez planifié
salaires la production de start 1 par
exemple c'est quoi votre
activités digitales
d'abord mes françois rebsamen l'adie
digital est un est un nouvel outil
formidable qui permet finalement de
d'avoir plus d'horizontalité le citoyen
finalement à d'un seul coup le même
pouvoir que l'élu qui peut interpeller
les services
plus de transversalité finalement ne
sont plus séparés les questions c'est
que les feux rouges peuvent être
connectés avec des questions de sécurité
à des questions de circulation voilà
donc quand on parlait de dépasser les
silos ben voilà on a un outil après on
connaît les limites il ya deux limites
principal tous les élus rond est à la
question des données ça s'en va en
parler on rit mais en conclusion
centrale c'est la question centrale
parce qu'on va parler données
individuelles qui remonte c'est à dire
celui qui a signalé le lan poule ça
devient quoi et c'est quelle est la
destination finale notable c'est pas
rien
centrale dans l'outil numérique on n'a
pas ignoré et et la deuxième le deuxième
élément la deuxième limite c'est il ne
faut pas donner le sentiment que ça
substitue à la démocratie on est et moi
d'ailleurs je me suis toujours méfié des
réseaux sociaux j'ai toujours dit par
exemple à mon équipe municipale les
réseaux sociaux ne seront jamais des
outils démocratiques jamais d'abord
parce qu'on ne se regardent pas dans les
yeux il ya une déshumanisation du
dialogue participatif et pour moi ce
n'est pas un outil démocratique donc
faut s'en méfier parce que souvent on
dit le numérique permettra aussi de
renforcer la démocratie y ont subi
d'ailleurs depuis qu'ils existent
réseaux sociaux la démocratie paraît
sûre et donc il faut se méfier aussi de
ça et de ne pas croire non plus que
l'outil est parfait l'outil a énormément
davantage il a des difficultés et je
pense qu'à un temps où on a beaucoup
besoin de démocratie de débats de
dialogue à l'intérieur de la population
parce que les enjeux de transition qui
arrivent vont bouleverser nos quotidiens
et je pense que ça vaut le coup qu'on en
parle qu'on se mette d'accord sur un
certain nombre de grandes stratégies
nous ne croyons pas que le numérique va
tout résoudre là c'est ça ce qu'a dit
françois est parfaitement juste sont des
outils formidables pour la
transversalité et pourboires réguler un
certain nombre de problèmes du quotidien
mais ça ne résoudra pas tout et le
politique restaurant encore bien en
place alors voyant le versant économique
jean hervé lorenzi vous avez entendu
deux élus dire qu'ils se sont mis à
cette activité digital à votre avis
cette digitalisation de l'économie créer
à la fois
des emplois et en détruit créer des
activités en détruit comment lutter
contre le solde négatif
du numérique parce qu'il existe le solde
négatif des questions parce que le s qui
vont la chine de la machine et de
l'homme
ça existe depuis c'est depuis le début
la première exigence d ip l'impé salle
et lui dise l'élu lice et c'est quand
même la seule le seul moment où quand
les ouvriers
anglais casser les machines s'est cassé
un objet on répandait ce qui était quand
même là on a fait des progrès depuis
oui et non parce que quand amazon dit je
créer des milliers d'emplois
et c'est vrai oui mais enfin il faut
voir ce qu'ils détruisent en
centre-ville comme donc la vérité est
intermédiaire moi je crois que le je
suis très en accord avec vos
interventions que le numérique est un
progrès
tout à fait sympathique important mais
je verrai utiliser votre terme si les
réguler j'ai tout à l'heure en entendant
françois parler de dijon je me voyais
arriver de du système chinois ou coup
quand un type traverse ce qu'il a
traversé il est il là on n'est pas loin
on
imagine on le photographie
en gros ça ça fait mal pour lui donc
c'est vrai que il faut
bien être lucide sur le fait que le
numérique est une et évidemment un
progrès pour notamment pour la
connaissance scientifique dans la vie
quotidienne il ya du voilà c'est une
balance et vaut mieux qu'elle penche du
côté positif notamment création
d'emplois
c'est pas évident aujourd'hui que la
balance au centre est occupé à passer le
sujet
c'est le sujet numéro un de ce débat et
alors vous en souvenez il y avait alfred
sauvy souvenait d'alfred sauvy il ne
connaît pas les
fans 'solides' et
économiques tout à fait remarquable mais
à mon avis deuxième grosse absurdité il
disait que quand on numérise canton
mécanise on baisse le coût de l'objet
qui produit afin d'un rang du pouvoir
d'achat à celui qui a acheté le bien
aimé la shell points chers et du coup il
va acheter d'autres biens qui eux sur -
numérique et donc ça va la balance va
être positive
objectivement alfred sauvy été
remarquable mais je sais que c'est
possible il faut donc faisons attention
raisonnement est que 2000 trop rapide
sur numérisation voilà alors écoutez
comme le temps et suez là on va conclure
avec vous hélène peskine et avec tous
les intervenants
on parle beaucoup de transition
énergétique de transition numérique de
progrès de digi la société digital et
cetera toutes ces données là il faut qui
a la maîtrise de ses données qu'est ce
qu'on peut en faire et comment
écologiquement si on peut dire mais
c'est je sais aussi éthiquement comment
gérer cette question la jambe ou plus
avec mon premier propos sur les sur la
place de l'europe d'abord on a un sujet
de souveraineté numérique en france et
en europe c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
mettre des plateformes qui gère la
plupart la très grande majorité des
données qu'elles soient des données très
local de mobilité par exemple ou des
données plus globale des réseaux sociaux
internationaux etc on a un projet à
construire avec l'europe autour de cette
logique de souveraineté numérique avec
des plateformes qui sont régulés et qui
sont comment dire cadrer juridiquement
par des normes européennes et donc qui
est 8 qu' il ya des fuites de données à
l'extérieur après je disais tout à
l'heure il faut apprivoiser le numérique
parce qu'il faut pas se priver
évidemment de ce que ça apporte on l'a
vu très bien à l'instant l'allemagne à
qu'il faut apprivoiser la mondialisation
des échanges en n'étant pas l'idiot dû
village global voilà en trouvant des
systèmes des conditionnements de taxe
carbone annexe à l'import etc il faut
trouver le système qui nous permet de
rendre le numérique utile notamment aux
usagers parce que il fait un peu peur
dans la ville en particulier quand on
parle de villes intelligentes les gens
voient des caméras partout et se dit ça
y est je suis surveillé en plus je sais
qu'ils me surveille c'est le maire de
dijon donc je suis allé frapper à sa
porte alors qu'ils sont surveillés en
permanence par google et apple et
personne ne se pose la question de
savoir ce qu'on fait de leurs données
donc il ya aussi cette question de la
confiance donnée aux assauts numérique
quand il quand il est utile aux
territoires elle a ajouté être bouclée
sur le projet dijonnais puisque on donne
assez rapidement parce qu'il nous reste
très peu de temps à la transition
écologique qui était aussi au coeur de
nos échanges on donne aussi grâce à ce
dispositif d information sur la qualité
de l'air sur l'astra colas de la densité
de la circulation sur la chaleur et la
température quand il fait très chaud et
c'est donc ça devient des outils au
service des citoyens et des usagers et
là on a apprivoisé l'outil du numérique
on commence à comprendre comment on peut
s'en servir merci si les skins françois
rebsamen qu'est ce que vous allez faire
de toutes les données que vous avez
ramassé avec andy gens je suis avec
votre plateforme digitale on a très
baissière c'est un vrai sujet je vais
vite c'est bien on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler à d'abord mis en place un
comité d'éthique c'est à dire que nous
avons des personnalités indépendantes du
monde juridique professeurs enseignants
citoyens lambda tirés au sort qui se
réunissent régulièrement pour vérifier
que les données qui seront recueillies
ne sont pas mises à disposition de
n'importe qui et des campagnes
électorales par exemple par exemple mais
là il n'y a pas besoin ça soit au niveau
national donc et ça existe et ils ont
déjà les fichiers de tout le monde de
via google et autres donc là ce comité
d'éthique il est présidé par un
magistrat il serait une île est
totalement indépendant il nous fait des
remarques on essaie d'en tenir compte
c'est un premier élément pour essayer de
régler ce problème puis après le
problème est plus général c'est comment
contrôler les fuites des data comment
contrôler cela bon il ya l'air gpd on
sait très bien quand même qu'il ya un
certain nombre de dispositions qui sont
prises il faut qu'on les applique le
plus strictement possible j'en suis
persuadé merci écoutait de l'émission
beaucoup de sang intéressante on aura
l'occasion de revenir là dessus le
moment est venu de vous présenter une
bibliographie alors ils peskine parmi
les publications du puca il y a des lois
laurent la métropole coopérative le
l'ouvragé lui alors en parle plutôt un
peu de ce que j'ai exprimé dans l'équipe
dans l'émission c'est à dire la
nécessité de construire ensemble la
transition notamment la transition
environnementale mais aussi démocratique
et donc la capacité qu'ont les grandes
villes en particulier à se lancer dans
des dispositifs démocratique singulier
qui sont des et nature de coopération de
construction collective merci redskins
alors jean hervé lorenzi vous avez
publié avec alain villemeur la grande
rupture
réconcilier 15 sessions peters est
question très importante mais en deux
mots c'est quoi cette grande rupture
ils iront à raison on est donc rentré
dans une trajectoire dès que le mondial
qu'est nouvelle
et dans ce livre que je trouve très bon
il est au fond il ya une proposition sur
la manière dont on peut mener une
trajectoire j'ai des créatrices qui va
vers le plein emploi en france françois
rebsamen vous avez publié en toute
confidence qu'est ce que vous voulez
confié de manière si intime ce que tout
le monde s est caché caché c'est à dire
la vie interne d'un ministère voilà vu
par un des acteurs de ce ministère bien
monsieur vers great vous avez préfacé
plusieurs ouvrages dont vers des villes
africaines durable santé territoires
chez 2 ctres
l'afrique vous préoccupe tant oui
surtout la problématique des villes il
se trouve que je vais aussi la casquette
de co président de la fédération
nationale des agences d'urbanisme pour
ça que j'ai préface est là et président
de franceville durable où justement on
essaie avec toutes les parties prenantes
de la ville durable d'essayer à la fois
de penser les concept de ville durable
mais aussi de donner des éléments très
concrets pour aider les élus locaux à
avancer dans cette question du
développement durable merci alors
écoutez je vous remercie je remercie
l'équipe d'el cp et je vous laisse avec
cette citation d'un auteur ancien jean
paul sartre
ce n'est pas dans je ne sais quelle
retraite que nous nous découvrirons
c'est sur la route dans la ville au
milieu de la foule choses parmi les
choses homme parmi les hommes
[Musique]